The Joe Rogan Experience now in
application of this thing one of the
things that we're seeing right now
um when we're talking about Quantum
Computing back to that
um one of the things we're seeing now is
chat GPT chat gbt which is this
fascinating uh AI program that
essentially scours the entire internet
for answers for things and is so good at
it the answers for things for just just
data people are getting diagnosed with
certain diseases based on symptoms and
blood work and it's super accurate uh
legal papers it could fill out legal
forms and it's it's wild the capacity
you can pass a bar exam that way too
yeah the bar exam can be passed with a
chat bot yeah it's like 98 right now
here's the question if quantum Computing
gets involved in AI what are we looking
at well first of all AI is a software
program we're talking about
homogenizing different kinds of essays
on the web splicing them together and
then passing it off as your latest
creation basically plagiarism using
digital computers it's a software
question however quantum computers is
bigger than that quantum computers is a
hardware question where it actually
increases your ability to do much more
than with an ordinary digital computer
so the two of them the chat Bots that
are revolution in software and then
quantum computers which are revolution
in Hardware when they get together watch
out so we're talking about an extremely
powerful alliance between software and
Hardware now also as you know chatbots
will also lie cheats Swindle Joe Oak and
do all sorts of crazy things if you're a
high school kid you could write all
sorts of Science Fiction scenarios and
some chat bot May grab pieces of that
nonsense and incorporate it into their
essay oh interesting so it can't discern
what's what's accurate exactly the whole
point this is the whole bottle of wax
chatbots do not know what is correct or
incorrect they just gather information
so they could be gamed that's right all
they do is homogenize cut up existing
things that sound human put it together
and then people say my God that sounds
like a human rodent of course a human
did write it it's not interesting that
they could game that also if they wanted
to find out what percentage of people
believed a certain thing if they had
some bad actor some foreign
you know governments that decided they
were going to spread narratives as
widely as possible and chat gbt just
gathers up all this information it could
give you an incorrect under
understanding of what's happening in the
world and give an incorrect
understanding of politics of the
economic point is that even though
there's a good aspect to all these
software programs the downside is that
you can fabricate truth because they
cannot tell the difference between false
and what is false and what is true
that's very interesting if you talk to
the chat uh the chatbot and say do you
know the difference between correct and
Incorrect and they say no it's just on
the web they're just instructed to
Cobble together existing paragraphs
splicing together and polish it up and
then spit it out but is it correct it
doesn't care it doesn't know so it is
essentially like an amazing resource of
information that's it's that's very
flawed that can't discern and can't
think I do this I have this problem all
the time I'm a professor and I give
assignments to the students sometimes
write a term paper so what do they do
some of them plagiarize oh how do you
catch them well you read the s say and
then you read another essay and you say
I've heard that before
right right the old-fashioned way yeah
but you see that's what a chatbot is a
chatbot is like a teenager that
plagiarizes other people's essays passes
it off as their own now I'm a scientist
we like to think about things that are
creative new Innovative things that will
change our perception of the world none
of that absolutely none of that comes
from a chatbot a chatbot simply
rearranges
pre-existing essays that's all it does
the the thing is though that's all it
does now that's what's interesting
what's interesting is what you're
talking about with Quantum Computing and
the insane computational power right and
then apply that to having access to all
of the information right but there's a
good aspect too you know when I write a
book
um my publisher has a fact Checker a
fact Checker that goes through all the
different statements that I make to make
sure that they're all correct there is
no fact checker for chat Bots let me
repeat that again there is no fact
checker for chat Bots that is the whole
bottle of wax that's the reason why
they're so dangerous because they can
they don't know these chatbots are
machines they don't know what is correct
what is incorrect it's all the same to
them that's the danger that they could
incorporate teenagers ranting and raving
about all sorts of garbage and put that
in with articles that sound reasonable
easy that's the problem now here's where
quantum computers coming in quantum
computers can act as a fact Checker you
can ask a quantum computer to remove all
the garbage remove all the nonsense in
these articles and it'll do that so in
other words the hardware may be a check
on some of the while statements made by
software but the problem with that is
who's the Arbiter of the information
like who decides what what's real and
what's not how does the chat bot decide
is a chat bot ideologically biased the
chatbot doesn't the chatbot is simply
the quantity does yeah Quantum Computing
and then it's going to be able to
discern what's real and what's not real
if they're gradations of what is true
like it is partially true or whatever it
could give you the the detailed
understanding of what it what could be
misconstrued what is partially correct
what is misleading but partially correct
you said I'm saying right now the
chatbot just splices it together like an
editor that's all it is and an editor
not a fact Checker and spits out Cobble
together articles that sound reasonable
but that could be Dynamite inside some
of these articles that were spliced into
what was proposed with a quantum
computer you can fact check things and
then you can say this is 90 correct this
is totally wrong this is sometimes
correct and you you get gradations of
what is correct and incorrect well if
you can get it objectively accurate fact
Checker that would be a huge step up
from what we have today because a lot of
people have very little faith in certain
fact Checkers and when you find out that
they're ideologically biased or they're
governmentally biased and if you could
have something that could just tell you
if you've been paying attention to how
Twitter is doing it now where they have
Community notes have you seen this no I
haven't it's interesting like say if
someone makes a statement about
something controversial climate change
whatever and then this controversial
statement gets refuted in the community
notes and then people will start
commenting and really intelligent very
well-read people on specific subjects
will chime in with peer-reviewed papers
and all these different statistics and
that show and then Twitter will correct
it and it will say readers have said and
then and then put up the relevant
information right see that's what uh
chatbots do not do today yeah they have
no understanding of correct or incorrect
false and true no understanding of that
but with Hardware coming into the
picture that's more advanced then yeah
you're talking about machines that can
do that automatically but it's the
problem who controls that machine like
say if China gets a hold of one of those
machines first if they develop a quantum
computer first and they start
implementing it well we have to make
sure that our quantum computers can
check other people's quantum computers
to make sure that they're not fudging
the facts right now remember that if
this is not done legally if there are no
laws passed in this direction and it's
in fact the wild west then of course the
politicians get involved and it becomes
a real mess now we do know that you
cannot yell fire in a crowded theater
therefore there are limits to free
speech and we get that but how do you
make limits on statements that are
written on the web that no human can
possibly follow right that's where
quantum computers can come in quantum
computers can are powerful enough to
survey the entire landscape and give
reasonable rebuttals to things that are
just outrageous well more than that it's
going to be able to instantaneously
change how we interact with each other
in terms of language barriers all these
issues that we have currently I'm sure
you you're aware of Google had
their earbuds there was a feature where
if say if you went to Spain you didn't
speak Spanish you could talk to it and
they would talk to it and it would
translate back and forth so you could
have a real-time conversation I'm not
sure how good is it how good is that Jim
but if there's something like augmented
reality and we have something like that
you're going to be able to
instantaneously translate what people
are saying
yeah there'll be no language barriers
for people no we'll be able to I think
that would change just human perception
across the world just the way we view
each other it's so easy to think of each
other as being different because we
speak a different language and we live
in a different part of the planet but
that would literally change how we
interact with each other yeah and just
remember that where do correct ideas
come from correct ideas come from
interaction with incorrect ideas it's
the it's the struggle between ideas out
of which correct ideas emerge and this
does not happen on the internet because
of course with chat Bots everything is
cobbled together cut splice and simply
glued together with Scotch tape
masquerading as an essay so with fact
tracking I think it's going to be
different Because unless we do fact
checking the politicians will get
involved yes and this is going to be a
real mess so I would hope that the
industry does fact checking by itself
rather than having politicians do it
it's such an important point that you
said where you said that the bad ideas
have to exist so the good idea is
triumph and that that's really an
argument against censorship on the
internet which is another problem that
people have especially censorship when
it comes to something being
ideologically based but when you're
you're thinking about Quantum Computing
I think I think this is small potatoes
right I think we're looking at literally
being able to change how we interact
with the universe like when we're
talking on our last podcast about the
preponderance of evidence that there's
things that operate inside of our
atmosphere that are Beyond imagination
that are they they operate with no
visible means of propulsion they move at
insane speeds we don't understand what
they are if we think about what Quantum
Computing is going to be capable of
that's the kind of stuff we're thinking
about right yeah you see quantum
computers are the ultimate computers
because they're competing on atoms if
there are aliens in outer space and I
think there are it means that they they
also have perfected quantum computers
and they can do calculations that are
far beyond anything that we can
calculate with like for example a
wormhole a wormhole in principle is a
gateway between two distant points of
space and time which allows you to break
the Einstein barrier and go faster than
the speed of light but the calculations
are horrendous it may take a quantum
computer to sort through what happens
when you go through a wormhole and wind
up on the other side of the universe and
the aliens probably already have done
that they've probably had centuries of
experience with quantum computers
because that's the ultimate computer you
can't compute in anything smaller than
an atom and they probably already have
used the quantum computers to navigate
through wormholes let's say
hypothetically it's so fascinating when
you think of where we were just a few
thousand years ago or a few hundred
years ago to where we are now and then
you imagine the invention of quantum
Computing you imagine everything just
the whole idea of whatever we think of
current computer progression just goes
out the window and it's insane
calculation capabilities
like we could be able to do something
like that in the future right quantum
computers allows us to calculate things
that are way beyond our ability to
calculate today like going through a
wormhole or warp drive or even the
question of multiple universes uh people
ask the question how come quantum
computers are so powerful it's because
they compute in in parallel universes
this is the Multiverse which of course
Marvel Comics has discovered and the
Oscars have discovered recently but the
Multiverse idea comes from quantum
physics electrons can be two places at
the same time now some people have a
hard time getting their head around that
but get used to it that's why we have
lasers that's why we have transistors
that's why we have the internet that's
why we have this conversation because
the electrons that are in this
microphone dance between universes at
the at the atomic level and so we have
to get used to the idea that quantum
computers introduces a whole new way of
looking at reality now reality is not a
Marvel comic but the idea of the
Multiverse comes from quantum physics
and that is electrons can be multiple
places at the same time